i
usually summarize this around four
reasons the first one
is probably the feeling with many
muslims that
we are not doing with the international
community not doing enough
to help the syrian opposition the syrian
spring in a way
and so they may feel that it's a duty
for them to go there and fight
the second one is linked to the
al-qaeda rhetoric the so-called jihad
that jihad has a specific meaning in
islam
but it may still be attractive for
for many and especially jihad in
al-sham greet syria it resonate
probably more than somalia or yemen the
third reason
is another feeling inside the muslim
community
in with the sunni one that they are
under threat
from the shia and finally a bit
disappointing
many cases the people were just
looking for the trill of uh the war
uh it's what i call a an excess of
testosterone they are
looking for the adventure they feel
maybe marginalized or isolated
and i think it's it's exciting it gives
them adrenaline to
to to take a kadashika and fight
i've mentioned the figure of 3000 plus
it's of course not exact uh fully
the last digit uh i'm just collecting
what ministers share with me what the
services share
but i think it's we can take it as a as
a reasonable figure
but it it takes all
uh the people who have been exposed to
the crisis in syria and
in iraq that means those who have died
there those who are still
fighting there those who have returned
and in
the french even take into account those
who have a serious intent to go there so
let's say three thousand plus how to
split that among the member states i
would say there is a core
group of nine to ten members say it's
more concerned by the phenomenon
mainly germany france belgium
the netherlands denmark sweden
uk a bit spain
and austria
well there is one obvious one the
killings
of four uh jews at the jewish museum
in in brussels um it seems that there
are there have been
some plots which have been foiled
our or security and uh law enforcement
agencies
um but we have to be vigilant because um
these people are trained to use
explosives
and weapons they are indoctrinated
by the salafi ideology they have
developed a network
around the mediterranean in the arab
world and
more more problematic in a way they have
raised significantly the level of
tolerance to violence
so um what do we do it it requires
member states to
assess each and every case each and
every returnee
to assess the dangerousness of the
person
then not all of them will not come back
in mount attack of course
many will need psychological support
because they will have this
post-traumatic stress
some will need just uh social support to
get
to know their life to get back to normal
life some will have to be
sent to a criminal court because they
have been part of a terrorist
organization they have committed war
crime or crime against humanity or just
terrorist crime
and where we don't have the evidence
because that's one of the challenge we
are faced with
because we're not present in syria we
will have and we assess that they are
dangerous
we will have to monitor them
the the eu as a as a group of 28 member
states has decided to react very quickly
in june 2013 ministers of interior have
adopted a quite comprehensive strategy
with more than 22 measures and we're
currently implementing
and it's around the following main
access first we have to understand
better the phenomenon so that requires
that member states share
all the information they have we have to
prevent people from being radicalized
and go to syria
and that requires a lot of work at local
level we have to detect suspicious
travel
and that requires the use of several
mechanisms we have to maximize
a database like the schengen information
system we have to set up
a new passenger name record we're
currently discussing that with japan
parliament
there is a need to deal with returnees i
just mentioned
how we should do the criminal law
aspect is important there is no current
debate as to whether the eu should not
have a common
definition of the behavior it's no
required by
the u.n security council resolution
adopted
last week under the chairmanship of
president obama
and finally we have to engage more with
third countries we have to help
especially
the country on the other side of the
military in north africa
because they too are confronted with the
phenomenon
ministers will first assess the
implementation of the
the package of measures that were
decided in june 2013
and explore further measures uh the
european council
in late august asked that the strategy
be implemented
more quickly and uh that we
explore possible new uh measures if need
be
so the main discussion will be on how to
secure this agreement with european
parliament on the setting up of an
uh european union passenger name record
uh the european council
would like it to be adopted by the end
of 2014
so we don't have much time to convince
the european parliament
and the second one is a more political
question
which is how do can we improve
the check at external borders
in two ways first check on on travel
documents
and there are ways to be more systematic
to use more
the interpol lost and stolen travel
document database
and the other one is a more sensitive
but political one i think very important
is shouldn't we contemplate a more a
systematic check
of eu citizens against the database so
if someone
is thought for arrest because he has
committed a murder
or someone is thought for arrest because
he went to syria and we know that it's
to join
the isil the terrorist organization or
jabata nusra
a systematic check would allow the
police to
arrest it at the border when they leave
and when they return so these are two
questions but there are
other technical aspects that minister
will discuss in order to boost the work
and just do what the european council
request them to do to be
to to work more quickly
you